Mike good morning how are you how are
you buddy well just trying to sort out
this Josh Allen situation should he have
done should he have gone through and
done interviews today well I I don't
know that there's an easy way for him to
dig out of this hole and look he's a
young kid still and he was even younger
and stupider when he did that the tweets
six seven years ago III don't I don't
know at this point what you do to undo
the damage and the problem is I think
somebody must have timed this cause
maximum mayhem right whether it's a
rival agent could be somebody from a
team that loves him and wants to get him
and you know what let's drop this stuff
out there so he slides down and we can
grab him I mean there's all sorts of
dirty things that happen around the
draft millions of dollars riding on it
futures of franchises and it's just it's
look I don't want to defend the content
it is what it is but for it all to come
up now it puts him in the worst possible
spot to try to sift through it so you
got to ask yourself am I gonna make it
better is there a chance I'm gonna make
it worse if there's any chance I'm gonna
make it worse it's better to say nothing
how do you think teams are gonna react
to this tonight I think it just depends
upon what each individual team thinks
how they assess it what their owner
thinks what the coach thinks what's the
what the GM thinks and you know yeah I
am inna mum if there's a team that calls
Josh Allen's agent says we want to get
him on the phone they'd better get on
the phone with them and if they have
questions he'd better answer them or
they're just gonna say forget it we
aren't we don't want this guy so even if
he doesn't say anything publicly he
better be ready to talk privately to any
team that wants to to talk to him about
this and figure out what happened of
course the broader issue is and the the
lesson to be learned apart from not
saying stupid things ever especially on
social media but when you know you're
going to be occupying a huge platform
you got to go back and clean that stuff
up and you'd think that the agent would
tell the players and if they haven't now
they need to tell them going forward you
got to go back and clean those things up
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on directiy
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]